Es ist schön.
Guten Tag. Ich heiße Dr. Korkmaz. Ich bin der Dienstherberge auf dieser Station.
Ich würde mit Ihnen auf Namen gesprochen. Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja, klar. Hauptsache, guckt ihr mal nach mir.
Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Beschwerden sprechen, möchte ich ganz schnell Ihre personische Daten aufnehmen.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Rudolf Pol. Und zwar Rudolf mit pH in Engeln.
pH, Rudolf und?
Und der Vorname Paul, der Familienname PoHL.
Paul. Herr Pol, wie alt sind Sie?
Noch bin ich 57. Im Mai werde ich 58.
Okay. Und wann sind Sie genau geworden?
Am 16. Mai 65.
16. Mai 65.
65. Okay.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,82 m.
Und wie viel wiegt ihr?
Ja, so circa 89, 90 kg, das bisschen schwankt das mal.
Okay. Okay. Herr Pol, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, also ich komme jetzt zu Ihnen, weil ich so heftigen Husten habe.
Und jetzt habe ich mit einmal auch richtig hohes Fieber bekommen.
Und ich habe so das Gefühl, ich kriege nicht gut Luft.
Ich muss so ein bisschen kämpfen, damit ich überhaupt Luft bekomme.
Heute Nacht habe ich unheimlich geschwitzt.
Und mein Kopf tut mir weh. Also ich fühle mich richtig krank.
Und bei dem Husten, da kommt so ein ganz komisches grünes Zeug raus.
Und es ist also ganz unangenehm.
Okay. Seit wann haben Sie Husten?
Ja, das hat vor fünf Tagen angefangen, aber da war das noch nicht so schlimm.
Und jetzt wird es halt immer heftiger.
Und als ich jetzt dann mit einmal hohes Fieber bekommen habe
und so das Gefühl hatte, ich kriege überhaupt gar keine Luft mehr.
Okay.
Seit gestern haben Sie Luftprobleme und Fieber, oder?
Ja, also in der Nacht habe ich das schon gemerkt, dass ich geschwitzt habe.
Und dann heute Morgen hatte ich auch wirklich starke Kopfschmerzen
und auch der Brustkorb hat mir so weh getan.
Und Brustschmerzen haben Sie?
Ja, ich habe die Brustschmerzen gemessen.
Darf ich fragen, haben Sie schon Fieber gemessen?
Ja, ich habe Fieber gemessen.
Das war kurz unter 39, 38, 39 oder so, unter dem Arm gemessen.
Okay.
Könnten Sie Ihre Brustschmerzen beschreiben, zum Beispiel drückend oder dumm?
Also auf der Einsage habe ich da so ein Druckgefühl,
das mir so die Luft wegnimmt.
Und dann habe ich aber auch das Gefühl,
dass es beim Husten richtig brennt.
Bei Husten?
Mhm.
Okay.
Und die Strahlen, die schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Nein, nein, nein.
Im Brustkorb ist es so, dass es irgendwo hinten ist.
Okay.
Im Moment haben Sie Brustschmerzen?
Nein, jetzt geht es so aufrecht, es geht, aber in der Nacht,
wenn ich gelegen habe, war es gar nicht gut.
Und beim Husten tut es natürlich weh.
Okay.
Ich denke, das ist nicht über, das ist nicht über eine Herzprobleme,
aber ich möchte sicher gehen, deswegen möchte ich eine EKG schreiben.
Okay, ja, das ist sicherlich eine gute Maßnahme.
Das dauert ja nicht lange, oder?
Ja, natürlich.
Und ich möchte Ihre Vitalparamette kontrollieren.
Okay.
Ja, was ist das?
Ihre Pulsch und Blutdruck und ja, so ist die Zeltung.
Okay.
Das machen Sie jetzt, ne?
Es ist unaufweilig, ich glaube.
Okay.
Jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen über Ihre allgemeine Zustand stellen.
Sie haben schon gesagt, sie hat Fieber und hat Sie Schweiß.
Sie haben Fieber.
Sie haben Fieber und ja, leiden Sie nach Schweiß.
Ich habe gesagt, ja, heute Nacht habe ich Fieber und Schweiß.
Ja, seit gestern, ja.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Also, Zeit bin ich nicht besonders gut.
Sonst normalerweise schmeckt es mir halt schon,
aber jetzt heute essen sicherlich nicht meine beste Beschäftigung.
Okay.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ab oder zugenommen?
Nein, nein, nein, das ist immer gleich.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme bei Wasserlassen oder bei Stullgang?
Nein, nein, da habe ich keine Probleme.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Schwindelig ist mir nicht nein.
Okay.
Wie viele Kissen brauchen, um zu schlafen?
Ja, normalerweise ein ganz normales Kissen.
Heute Nacht habe ich ein bisschen drunter gepackt,
weil ich so husten musste.
Und trotzdem konnte ich eigentlich nicht gut schlafen.
Ich musste mich immer wieder aufsetzen und auf die Kante setzen.
Das war eine unruhige Nacht.
Okay.
Es war nur ein letzter Nacht.
Ja, ja, ja.
Okay, Herr Pol.
Haben Sie, früher haben Sie ein Vorerkrankungen,
wie Blutzucker oder Blutokdruck, Zuckerkrankheit?
Also das einzige, was bei mir bekannt ist,
dass ich seit fünf Jahren Gicht habe.
Und vor fünf Wochen war das,
da hatte ich mal so eine heftige Attacke in einem Fuß.
Aber sonst, ja, ich hatte natürlich Rückenschmerzen,
dann war es eine Arbeit.
Und dann habe ich noch so eine Kleinigkeit.
Wenn ich in die Sonne gehe, habe ich hier so im Schlefenbereich,
kriege ich da so Hautveränderungen.
Insofern muss ich das immer gut schützen im Sommer.
Da bin ich da keine Sonnenbestrahlung drauf.
Ich glaube, dass Sie eine Sonnenallergie haben.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das eine wirkliche Allergie ist.
Keine Ahnung, wie das genau heißt.
Okay.
Und gibt es noch etwas?
Nein, nein, ich bin nicht ganz fit.
Okay.
Okay, Herr Pol.
Nennen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente regelmäßig ein?
Ja, also ich nehme eben diese Salbe dafür,
für diesen Schlefenbereich da.
Das heißt Solaratze gehe.
Und das mache ich halt im Sommer einmal im Morgen
und einmal im Mittag.
Könnten Sie wiederholen?
Das heißt Solaratze.
Okay.
Nur am Sommer.
Ja, also nur wenn Sonnenbestrahlung ist,
wenn ich draußen bin.
Und dann nehme ich noch Zylorik 300.
Alle Pyrnole, ich glaube nicht.
Bitte?
Ist das alle Pyrnole?
Ich meine ja, meine.
Eine morgens.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen irgend welche Allergie oder
Unvertretigkeit bekannt?
Ja, tatsächlich habe ich eine Allergie auf Amoxicillin.
Das darf ich nicht bekommen.
Da bekomme ich einen ganz heftigen Hautauschlag davon.
Okay.
Und ich habe, ja,
ja, ja, ja, ja.
Würden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, ich hatte,
ja, auch Berufskrankheit, denke ich,
vor 13 Jahren eine Kapaltunnel-Operation.
Kapalt.
Okay.
An der rechten Seite, ne?
An der rechten Seite, okay.
Wenn Sie Vorsicht an die Game gegen Corona auf?
Ja, auf alle Fälle, klar.
Okay.
Und rauchen Sie Harpoil?
Ja, viel rauch ich nicht mehr,
aber ein bisschen kann ich es nicht sein lassen.
Also so ein halbes Päckchen am Tag rauch ich immer noch.
Jetzt die letzten Tage natürlich nicht.
Aber sonst rauch ich schon viele Jahre.
Seit ich 19 bin oder so?
90, ungefähr, ja, 39 Jahre.
Mhm.
Ja, okay.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, Alkohol kann man das nicht nennen.
Ich trink also abends eine Flasche Bier,
aber mehr eigentlich auch nicht.
Okay.
Nächste Frage ist eine Routine Frage.
Haben Sie Erfahrungen mit Drogen?
Mit Drogen? Nein, das ist eine Routine Frage.
Und wir haben fast fertig gemacht,
aber ich möchte ein paar Fragen über Ihre
Familienstand und Familiegeschichte stellen.
Ihre Eltern leben in Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, die leben beide noch,
aber es geht ihnen gesundheitlich nicht gut.
Leiden Sie irgendwelche Anerkrankungen?
Ja, also mein Vater, der hat im Bergbau gearbeitet,
der hat eine Staublunge.
Und meine Mutter, das ist gar nicht lange her.
Vor vier Wochen hatte sie eine Darmooperation,
die hatte so Verwachsenen im Darm.
Und da hatte sie den Darmverschluss und das musste operiert werden,
aber jetzt erholt sie sich langsam wieder.
Okay.
Karl-Paul, wie ist Ihre Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, wir haben drei Kinder,
aber die beiden Großen sind schon aus dem Haus.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, der Kleine, der noch bei uns ist,
der ist natürlich ein bisschen unser Sorgenkind,
der hat das Down-Syndrom.
Aber er wird eigentlich sehr gut betreut.
Okay.
Ich weiß, das bedeutet, ich hatte auch eine Baustandrome,
Bratbrüder.
Ah, okay.
Ja.
Okay. Was machen Sie bei sich?
Ich bin Florist.
Florist.
Okay.
Paul.
Ich möchte eine kleine kurze Zusammenfassung machen.
Vor fünf Tagen hat Ihre Husten aufgetreten.
Ist der Husten aufgetreten?
Ja, er ist aufgetreten.
Seit gestern werden sie stärker.
Und auch seit gestern haben sie Fieber.
Und Atemprobleme.
Ja, das stimmt wirklich.
Und Kopfschmerzen und Brustschmerzen haben sie.
Ja, ja.
Okay.
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas fragen oder hinzufingen?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob das noch wichtig ist.
Also, ich habe tatsächlich auch noch so eine Schnupfnase.
Und einmal hatte ich auch heftiges Nasenbluteln.
Aber das ist zum Glück schnell wieder weggegangen.
Seit gestern?
Das war vorgestern, glaube ich.
Vorgestern.
Okay.
Okay, noch etwas?
Nein, jetzt will ich natürlich wissen, was kann man dagegen machen?
Muss ich hier bleiben oder kann ich Medikamente bekommen,
damit ich wieder schnell besser werde?
Was kann man machen?
Ja, ich verstehe Sie natürlich.
Sie wissen, wie es läuft.
Wir haben schon die Aufnahmegesprache durchgefüllt.
Und ich muss ja ein paar Tests durchführen,
um ihre Krankheit zu diagnostisieren.
Ja, erst einmal führe ich körperliche Untersuchungen durch.
Und danach nehme ich Blut ab und dann eine Röntgen-Torax-Röntgen-Lungen verhalten lassen.
Also eine Röntgenaufnahme der Lunge.
Ja, das ist auf die Lange nicht gewacht worden bei mir.
Ja, und dann, nach wieher die Ergebnisse bekommen,
werden wir widersprechen.
Ja, das klingt gut.
Dann hoffe ich mal, dass das nicht so lange dauert.
Als klar.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen andere Fragen?
Haben Sie aus Furf?
Ja, habe ich gesagt, kommt so grünes Zeug draußen.
Ja, wie sieht aus?
Grün.
Hab ich nicht bemerkt, aber grün habe ich bemerkt.
War ich in einem Ausland oder eine Reise gemacht?
Nein, ich habe keine Reise gemacht.
Ich habe eine ähnliche Symptome.
Sonst hat niemand so etwas nacheinander.
Nein.
Könnten wir anfangen?
Ja, ich fange schon.
Ja, super.
Guten Tag, mein Oberarztin.
Ich habe eine neue Patient.
Ich möchte Ihnen vorstellen,
haben Sie dafür größer Zeit?
Ja, wirklich.
Wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Herr Rudolf Pol ist 57-jährige Patient.
Er kann heute wegen bestehender und zunehmender Hüsten zu uns.
Er berichtet, dass er Fieber hat.
Er hat 39 gemessen.
Er ist unterarmt.
Und er klackte auch über Dyspner,
Sephalgie und Angina.
Angina ist drückend und brennend bei Hüsten.
Ich habe ein EKG verschreiben.
Es war verschrieben,
wird geführt und es war unauffällig.
Ich habe Glück.
Ja.
Er klagte auch nach Schweiß und Appetitlosigkeit in Appetanz.
Die restlichen relativ Panamnese sind unauffällig.
An vor krankungen leidet er Hypergurikemi seit fünf Jahren.
Und vor 30 Jahre wurde er wegen Carpal Syndrome operiert.
Er nimmt regelmäßig alle drühneu 300 Milligramm morgens ein.
Ich bin nicht sicher, aber er hat eine Sonnalergie.
Er nutzt eine Salve.
Es heisst Doloratze.
Er hat eine Amoxicillinallergie.
Die äußert sich durch Exanten.
Er raucht seit 39 Jahren halbe Packet-Sirrate.
Er trinkt ein Flasche abends.
Er wurde verneint.
Er ist verheisatet.
Er hat drei Kinder.
Der kleine ist Down syndrome.
Hat das Down syndrome?
Er ist vollständig geimpft gegen Corona.
Er ist floristisch.
Er leidet an Pynomoconius.
Ja, und seine Mutter wegen Illyus operiert wurde.
Die Mutter wurde kürzlich wegen Illyus operiert.
Ja, das war alles.
Ja, aber was haben Sie denn jetzt für eine Verdachtsdiagnose?
Aufgrund der anonystischen Angabe gehe ich eine Pynomonie aus.
Als Differenzialdiagnose kommen auch KHA und Corona in Betracht.
Ja, das hätte man wahrscheinlich, fällt mir jetzt gerade ein, so aktuell, man hätte gefragt, ob der ein Corona-Test gemacht hat, oder?
Ja, aber ich weiß mir jetzt auch erst eingefallen, ja.
Aber was könnte es denn auch noch sein?
Äh, die kleine Schwester von Corona.
Grippe könnte es ja auch?
Ja, Grippe, ja Grippe und Arachmein.
Influencer, ja.
Okay, gut. Was machen Sie denn, die haben noch nicht mit dem Patient?
Erst mal, weil ich Körperliche Untersuchungen durchführen.
So, um worauf achten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchungen?
Die Lungengeräusche, besonders achte ich.
Was erwarten Sie?
Ich habe eine Ron-Küs-Rall.
Ein Rassel.
Rassel, ja, Rassel, ja, Rassel.
Und Auskultation?
Ja, auch auskultation.
Was erwarten Sie da?
Die Gebäusche.
Ja, ist das?
Perkussion, Timpanische.
Timpanische Perkussion, ja.
Okay.
Gut. Und was machen Sie labortlich nicht?
Ich kontrolliere Großbrötbild,
Entsündeparameter, CRP, BCG,
und Leberwerte, Nierenwerte.
Okay, ja, sehr gut, in Ordnung, halber, vielleicht, ja.
Und was untersuchen Sie noch im Labor?
Ich habe mal ein Röntgen-Torax.
Was machen Sie im Labor noch?
Ein Schilderung, Labor.
Den Dimmer, und...
Das meinte ich jetzt gerade nicht.
Herzparameter, ja, natürlich, ich habe schon EKG kontrolliert.
Und Herz...
Ich meine aber noch etwas anderes.
Ich schäbe Küte, Auswurfküte, ja.
Auswurfküte.
Auswurf, ne, Sputumkultur, genau.
Jawohl.
Und natürlich Röntgen-Torax, was erwarten Sie im Röntgenbild?
Eine Lobber-Oder...
Die Zylunge ganz normal aus?
Ja, es könnte sein.
Aber bei Lobberpinomonie, eine...
Ein Schatten.
Ein Schatten, ja.
Jawohl, ja.
Gut, was machen Sie denn jetzt mit Herrn Poel, wenn Sie den durchdiagnostiziert haben?
Und es weist alles darauf hin, dass der eine Pylomonie hat.
Was machen Sie damit?
Er ist klein, 65 Jahre alt und gibt es einen Scala.
Ist das schon Behandlung oder ambulant Behandlung?
Aber man muss ja auch ein bisschen gucken, wie es irgendwie wie seine Luftloat ist, ne.
Wie ihr gesehen, ist nicht so schlimm, sonst wäre das, was ich wäre, die Sauerstoffsetigung extrem schlecht gewesen.
Ja.
Ja, was machen wir denn mit Ihnen?
Als ambulant Therapie.
Zum Beispiel, ja.
Wenn Sie ihn nicht stationär aufnehmen, was kriegt er denn dann?
Eine Amplikantibiotiktherapie schreibe ich.
Ja, und worauf achten wir dabei?
Er hat Amoxicillinallerin, deswegen ich werde eine Makrolit.
Ja, und man muss gucken, was bei der Kultur rauskommt.
Ja, natürlich.
Dass man dann keinen Bereich, praktisch, was draufbricht.
Und welche Medikamente so zur Erleuchterung er leichter um würden Sie ihm noch geben?
Als Antibiotiker.
Nein, andere Medikamente um das zu erleichtern, seine Erleuchter.
Ja, eine Makrolüse, ich schreibe in der Politik, als es für sich ist.
Also es ist ja, und das noch vielleicht?
Also für sich ist es für sich.
Und für eine Antikreatik für seine Fieber.
Genau.
Ja, gut.
Dann gucken Sie, was aus Ihrem Patienten inzwischen geworden ist, halten Sie mich bitte auf dem laufenden.
Ja, sehr gut.
Okay, wie viele Animesen haben Sie schon gemacht auf der Kurkmas?
Das ist die Dritter.
Boah, super.
Wissen Sie, was mir aufgefallen ist? Sie sprechen ziemlich langsam.
Und sobald Sie merken, da ist ein Fehler drin, korrigieren Sie das selber.
Sie merken das.
Ja.
Und da merkt man, dass Sie mit der Sprache einfach ziemlich gut vertrauten.
Sie sagen etwas und hören, hey, das klingt nicht richtig.
Und dann drehen Sie es eben oder so.
Super, das war richtig gut.
Ein paar Mal habe ich ja etwas gesagt, aber nicht so furchtbar oft.
Und es war für mich auch möglich zu intervenieren, weil Sie eben nicht so wahnsinnig schnell gesprochen haben.
Da konnte ich noch so dazwischenkommen und sagen, so und so heißt es.
Das wäre super.
Und also die Animese fand ich sehr strukturiert und folgerichtig.
Und natürlich super reagiert, dass Sie Vitalparameter geprüft haben und Monitorien gemacht haben, bevor Sie weitergefragt haben.
Ja, und auch im Bericht waren Sie meine ich sehr vollständig.
Ich wüsste nicht, dass da irgendwas war, was Sie da unterschlagen haben, was Sie nicht erzählt haben.
Also.
Und wie gesagt, wenn immer Sie gemerkt haben, oder es stimmt jetzt, sprachlich nicht, dann haben Sie selber eigentlich schnell korrigiert.
Das geht aber nur, wenn man tatsächlich ein bisschen ruhig ist.
War super.
Und guck uns mal, wir haben eigentlich nicht mehr Zeit gebraucht als andere auch.
Man kann das in der relativ knappen Zeit schaffen.
Und trotzdem war das, würde ich sagen, eine sehr vollständige Angelegenheit.
Super, sehr schön.
Vielen Dank.
Mein Problem ist bei Arztars Sprache.
Manchmal erinnere ich mich nicht, was ich sagen soll.
Oder ich weiß, aber ich weiß nicht die deutsche Fachwerte.
Ja gut.
Also das ist sicherlich noch ein bisschen ausbauffähig.
Da waren jetzt ein paar Lücken, dass sie, wie heißen das?
Aber das ist ja, wie Vokabeln lernen.
Dass man einfach nochmal die Fachterminologie sich anguckt, das bedeutet das ja.
Und das hat aber nichts mit Sprache oder so zu tun.
Klar ist es für die Fachsprache wichtig, dass man die richtige Terminologie benutzt.
Aber wenn da mal ein Begriff fehlt, okay, da kann Ihnen auch jemand auch die Sprünge hält.